ich habe das noch nie vor einem video
gesagt aber hier ist das absolut nötig
bitte schaut dieses video nicht wenn er
nicht beunruhigt werden wollt beendet
die wiedergabe jetzt gestern wurden die
regeln für die triage in deutschland
bekannt gegeben es sind die regeln
die ärzten und ärztinnen helfen sollen
zu entscheiden welche patientinnen und
patienten bei mangel an ausrüstung und
personal behandelt werden und welche
sterben gelassen werden nach dem
jetzigen stand werden die
kapazitätsgrenzen am elften april
erreicht aber es gibt hoffnung dass
diese situation später eintritt zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen aber
schnell die situation außer kontrolle
geraten kann haben wir in italien
gesehen und sehen es gerade in new york
33.000 infizierte stand 26 märz dort
acht uhr 366 sind bisher gestorben zur
zeit verdoppelt sich die zahl der
neuansteckungen alle drei tage am 23
märz waren es noch 6000 heute werden es
voraussichtlich 12.000 neue infektionen
sein und so weiter und so fort nur in
new york eine ähnliche entwicklung wird
es bei den toten geben in etwa zehn
tagen werden jeden tag dort etwa 6000
opfer dazu kommen der bundesstaat ist
vollkommen überfordert schon jetzt wurde
ein leichen zelt für 26.000 tote
aufgestellt und die opferzahlen könnten
höher werden weil es einfach kaum
kapazitäten zur behandlung geben und ich
kann es nur noch mal ja
gebetsmühlenartig wiederholen
der verlauf ist exponentiell
das widerspricht unseren erfahrungen
aber jeden tag werden es mehr mehr der
verlauf hängt dabei von zahlreichen
rahmenbedingungen ab welche
bevölkerungskreise werden zuerst
angesteckt junge oder alte wie ist die
bevölkerungsstruktur wie ist das
gesundheitssystem ausgelegt wie hat man
sich darauf vorbereitet in deutschland
ist das gesundheitssystem im prinzip
sehr gut ausgelegt allerdings gibt es zu
wenig personal und zu wenig ausrüstung
das bundesgesundheitsministerium hat
trotz warnung von expertinnen und
experten und aus der branche viel zu
spät reagiert als jens spahn betonte
dass unser gesundheitssystem gut
vorbereitet sei hätte er es besser
überprüft und es tatsächlich darauf
vorbereiten sollen das ist scheinbar
nicht geschehen jetzt haben wir zu wenig
schutzausrüstung und die note bestellung
werden dann
auch noch auf dem transportweg gestohlen
wie vor zwei tagen in kenia wo sechs
millionen masken verschwunden sind und
der mangel an schutzausrüstung bedeutet
dass sich auch ein signifikanter teil
des gesundheitspersonals anstecken kann
was zu weiteren engpässen führen kann
die lage ist also ernst und deshalb
haben gestern sieben ärztevereinigungen
die regelungen zur triage also der
entscheidung zwischen leben und tod
bekannt gegeben der sperrige titel
entscheidungen über die zuteilung von
ressourcen in der notfall- und der
intensivmedizin im kontext der gofit 19
pandemie
ja das ist es das papier ist man kann es
nur so sagen ist schlimm es betrifft
auch nicht nur gut 19 erkrankte sondern
alle menschen die behandelt werden wir
kennen das aus dem krankenhaus oder aus
berichten darüber
hier in deutschland wird so lange
behandelt bis die erkrankten sterben
diese regelung wird aufgehoben wenn ein
krankenhaus nicht mehr alle opfer mit
einem schweren krankheitsverlauf
behandeln kann und schon gebrechlichkeit
also ein besonders alter mensch kann
bedeuten dass dieser mensch nicht mehr
behandelt wird und sterben muss aber
grundsätzlich wird ab einem bestimmten
punkt abgewägt dann werden die
erfolgsaussichten einer behandlung
abgewogen zum beispiel einer
vorerkrankung und vor allem der
vergleich zu anderen menschen die
intensiv behandelt werden sprich
erkrankte mit guten behandlungschancen
schlagen immer die mit schlechten
chancen in den empfehlungen heißt es aus
gerechtigkeits erwägung sollten bei der
priorisierung alle patienten
gleichermaßen berücksichtigt werden das
heißt bei der einlieferung und auch
danach wird immer überprüft ob dieser
patient oder diese patientin bessere
chancen hat als der schlimmste fall in
diesem krankenhaus dessen behandlung
wird abgebrochen und er wird sterben
gelassen dafür gibt es dann dieses
formular auf dem dann die
entscheidungsfindung dokumentiert wird
und wenn hier palliativstation
angekreuzt wird ist das das todesurteil
dort wird nicht mehr behandelt sondern
nur noch gepflegt und die schmerzen
gelindert aber es gibt neben den vielen
problemen einen kleinen silberstreif am
horizont die steigerungsrate der
fallzahlen die geht weiter nach unten
gestern ist die zahl der neuinfektionen
im vergleich zum vortag nur um 13
prozent gestiegen
vom 4332 neuinfektionen auf 4000
195 wenn diese steigerung so anhält
haben wir am elften april 39.000 neue
infizierte statt heute knapp 5000 damit
wäre die grenze für das deutsche
gesundheitssystem erreicht am zwölften
april wäre es überlastet im moment sieht
es aber so aus dass die steigerung der
zahl der neuinfektionen langsam sinkt
und das könnte wirklich heißen dass wir
die kurve im wahrsten sinne des wortes
noch ganz knapp kriegen ich drücke uns
allen die daumen wie geht es weiter mit
dem live stream heute am 26 märz vom sn
1054 kanal breaking lab wir gegen korona
anklicken anschauen natürlich auch
danach der link funktioniert auch für
die aufzeichnung also bleibt gesund bis
dann bleib dran